what a revelation he's been all year for
the braves and since he's come off the
injured list he's been very impressive
as well yeah two great starts uh since
he's come back off was really good
against the yankees give up that one
home run other than that i thought he
was
magnificent you look at
his 11 games this season opponent's
hitting just 200 one thing he's done so
good chip
left-handed hitters hitting a buck 74
against him with no home runs stella
though over his last 12 games a 324
batting average bostella drives that one
out to right field no heroic catch this
time it's gone
tommy lestella who nearly was the hero
in the ninth inning last night this one
was a lot farther than that almost 400
feet to put the giants ahead logan webb
coming on for his 19th start of the
season 7-3 105 strikeouts in those 98
innings and he's just been on a great
streak two earned runs or less in each
of his last 12 starts good lead at first
for ozzie he's taking off pitch is a
ball the throw to second to strike today
and albies has his 17th stolen base
stella thought ozzie came off the bag
kept the tag applied but won't get that
call
got him with the slider
two and two
slider struck him out swinging
two down
well not all sliders are created equal
does not get it down and in ends up
backing up a little bit but again if you
could bottle those up if any pitcher
would tell you if they can bottle up a
cement mix and slider that ends up not
breaking the way it should they would
because that's the kind of swing you end
up getting one thing you will notice
with dansby swanson is with two strikes
he does choke up about an inch or two on
that bat you can see it slider on the
ground to short crawford will just go to
the stella for the force out so
webb gets the ground ball plus a couple
strikeouts no runs giants lead
one-nothing
as you know strikes out dickerson
looking his first punch out of the game
he's now set down four straight
one like dickerson got just kind of a
get me over tight
this one rolled over to third riley's
got that that was a nice sequence from
wascarinor three up three down with a
strikeout of alex dickerson one-nothing
giants
i mean i can't even read this it's so
amazing the numbers marshall finished
with his career with 243 wins
244 complete games amazing bare hand
play wilbur flores got him what a nice
play by wilmer flores to start the
bottom of the second
bare hand play it's the only chance you
have comes in gets the steps right
barehand toss
throws a strike over to darren ruff and
actually not as close as
you thought it was initially what do you
think buster's telling him
dude you cost my pitcher a pitch
that's what he's telling him look webb
gets the strikeout we go to the third
one nothing giants
full count pitch and he noah pulled a
string yastremski takes strike three
that's a perfect example
3-1 3-2 gets a slider you go back last
inning chip darren ruff 2-0 slider 2-1
slider that's just a beautiful pitch
pulled that one on the ground and it's
fair by the dive of riley down the left
field line logan webb is going to dig
for second and he'll make it there then
the throw gets away but not far enough
to advance
webb to third it's a double
nobody may be more comfortable with two
strikes
in the game than this guy
he hits that one high in the air to
right field now this is probably deep
enough we'll see so lair
is gonna catch webb is gonna tag and the
throw is coming to second so logan webb
scores la stella gets the sacrifice fly
it's two nothing giants
again a 3-2 pitch
high fly ball jammed him who wants it
ozzy is there and makes the play
and shallow right center field in front
of jack peterson that ball hung up
forever
3-2
is swung on it missed strike three
that's not a walk that's a strikeout
sets up that slider
gorgeous cheese down the middle how
about that
two down
logan webb when he's getting in trouble
that's what's happening he's just
releasing a tad too early
fly ball left center mike yostremski
there
out number three
graves threaten they do not score we go
to the fourth two nothing giants lead
first pitch popped up
and dansby in the shift ranges out and
puts the squeeze on that he knows out of
the fourth without much difficulty time
for the braves bats to go to work
second in the national league with those
runs batted in that's pretty amazing
adam duvall
right up the middle and right to la
stella crawford kicks the bag
double play
all right two pitches two outs
goes a little bit of a kick save tries
to make it doesn't get it goes right to
estella
and like you mentioned crawford with
that little toe tap
better than anybody makes it look so so
pretty
you one pitch base runner then the next
pitch double play jack peterson all the
way to the warning track
and dickerson makes the catch and that's
a three pitch inning
you can't do better than that can you
not really
fly ball center
but playable for jack peterson andy noah
has a much needed easy inning one two
three and out goes san francisco oscar
leads off the atlanta fifth
[Applause]
got him with the slider man logan webb
these last two innings just dominant
that one took him all of nine pitches he
had to really dig deep there we go to
the six two nothing giants so that's
what you gotta live a little bit i guess
with that too
swaying and a miss sanoa with a nice
piece of pitching to take care of
dickerson on strikes for the second time
he's keeping the braves in the game now
you got a chance he can get a ground
ball here to get out of it with no
damage done we'll see travis darno
back to webb he'll get the out at second
la stella to first got him double play
and the giants get out of it what a
great job by logan webb last night
tonight big outs and big moments team
building that's exactly what it is
ostremski drives that one out to left
center field
going back peterson all the way to the
wall and it's gone mike kastrekski
to left center field his 21st of the
year three nothing giants that's a
beautiful swing
comes darren ruff infield hit you could
score a run
allen ripped into left field base hit
darren ruff is gonna bring home buster
posey four-nothing giants
great two-strike swing from darren ruff
[Applause]
stremski out into left center field that
one's gonna get down and that's gonna be
another run
peterson will cut it off wilmer coming
in
he scores into second standing
yostremski
five nothing giants
travis darneau then adam duvall and jack
peterson
right there strike three call with that
fastball
slider struck him out swinging two down
how about jay jackson he's got a chance
to strike out the side here to finish
out the game
2-2
struck him out with the slider jay
jackson strikes out the side
you